okay Donald Trump's press secretary
Kaley Mackin Annie visibly and audibly
failed to explain why Donald Trump is
accusing TV host joe scarborough of
murder on twitter during a press
briefing yesterday this was I believe
her shortest press briefing in a long
time I think it was 16 minutes only she
barely takes questions and often just
aborts when it gets a little bit dicey
and you have to see this to believe it
so to catch you up yesterday I told you
that Donald Trump spent the weekend as
the United States coronavirus death toll
approached and has now surpassed 100,000
Trump spent the weekend not just golfing
but also retweeting that Hillary Clinton
is a skank and accusing MSNBC host joe
scarborough of murder i showed you these
tweets yesterday we'll go over them one
more time Trump tweeting quote a lot of
interest in this story about psycho Joe
Scarborough so a young marathon runner
just happened to faint in his office hit
her head on his desk and died
I would think there is a lot more to
this story than that an affair what
about the so-called investigator Reid
story
referring to a three year old right wing
nut story Trump also tweeting a blow to
her head body found under his desk left
Congress suddenly big topic of
discussion in Florida he's a nut job
with bad ratings keep digging use
forensic geniuses and as I told you
yesterday what this all relates to is a
Scarborough staffer that tragically died
in 2001 the woman was 28 year old Lori
kiss loudest clip class Udhas may be
better better pronounced and of course
Kaylee Mackin Annie was asked about this
and the nearly two minute answer that
she gives is bizarre it's a combination
of what about ISM condescension
incompetence and lies let's look at it
together and I apologize for subjecting
you to a little more than 90 seconds of
this but I think it is important to
understand the full answer that she gave
or not answer that she gave
allegations the president accusing
somebody of possibly murder the family
is pleading with the president to please
stop found in conspiracy theories why is
he doing it well you know I would note
that the president said this morning
that this is not an original Trump
thought on and it is not in fact 2003 on
Don Imus show it was Don Imus and joe
scarborough that joked about killing an
intern joked and laughed about it so
that was I'm sure pretty hurtful to
Laurie's family and Joe Scarborough
himself brought this up with Don Imus
and Joe Scarborough himself and he's
accusing somebody of possibly murder
this is different he's he's not a
private citizen he's the president yeah
and Joe Scarborough if we want to start
talking about false accusations we have
quite a few we can go through about mica
asserting time to you and saying this
morning as recently I believe was this
morning or yesterday mica accused the
president of being responsible for a
hundred thousand deaths in this country
that's incredibly irresponsible they've
dragged his family through the mud
they've made false accusations that I
won't go through that I would not say
from this podium against the President
of the United States and they should be
held to account for their falsehoods Joe
Scarborough should be held to account
for saying people will die by taking
hydroxychloroquine
never mind the millions of Americans and
people across the world who take it for
rheumatory arthritis and other reasons
there are litany of false headlines like
Nica false conspiracy theory that's
possible for murder I would point you
back to Joe Scarborough who laughed and
joked about this item on Don Imus to
show it's Joe Scarborough the hats to
answer these questions why is the
president doing this was the question
why is the president accusing someone of
murder and the family of the of the
victim is saying please stop Caylee
Mackin Annie's answer is Trump didn't
come up with the idea that Scarborough
murdered someone and Joe Scarborough and
Don Imus joked about murdering an intern
once now
joking about murdering an intern might
be in bad taste but it had nothing to do
with this actual
to say Trump is justified in tweeting
that maybe Joe Scarborough killed Laurie
caseload is has nothing to do with Joe
Scarborough and Don Imus joking maybe in
poor taste about killing an intern
secondly Joe Scarborough and Don Imus
were not the presidents of the United
States they weren't President of the
United States tweeting bogus death
accusations bogus killing allegations to
their eighty million followers which is
what Donald Trump is doing then she says
well joe scarborough's co-host mika
brzezinski once said things we believe
to be false about Donald Trump Mika
Brzezinski is not the president Donald
Trump is the president there is no
relevance or comparison now in terms of
hydroxychloroquine people have died from
taking it but again that has nothing to
do with Trump accusing people of murder
on Twitter we're a joke guys I hate to
say it but we're a joke we have a
petulant incompetent child as the
president tweeting conspiratorial murder
allegations against the TV host that he
simply doesn't like the president is
accusing people of murder on Twitter the
press secretary is defending it by
saying well other people said things we
don't like that's the defense but we're
talking about the president she has
nothing to say in reality because there
is nothing to say she represents nothing
she is the spokeswoman for a madman and
she doesn't care how does she sleep at
night she claims to be some kind of
supposed Christian that's probably a
story for another day but absolutely
unconscionable what Trump is doing how
Caylee maggin annie is defending it and
the complete lack of Donald Trump ever I
mean he you know earlier I jokingly said
Trump apologized for tweeting fake news
he just never he doesn't take
responsibility for anything he doesn't
take responsibility for the unnecessary
coronavirus deaths which are not the
full hundred thousand of course right a
me but but some fraction certainly would
have been avoided up to sixty percent
according to a recent study had Trump
acted earlier he doesn't take
responsibility for lack of testing he
doesn't just say you know what it was
over the line to go after Joe
Scarborough in this unfounded way it did
unnecessary pain to the family of the
victim Laurie Kozlov he will never do it
he will never do it and if you're
holding your breath waiting for him to
do it you will soon die from from
asphyxiation because he's simply not
going to do it
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy comm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman